premier 870 personnes vont se retrouver
sans emploi suite au départ de délits
verrous le groupe britannique a fait le
choix d'arrêter ses activités en espagne
suite à la loi ryder la loi impose aux
sociétés faisant des livraisons à
domicile via des applications numériques
d'embaucher comme salariés tous leurs
vivres heures jusqu'à présent les
livreurs travailler avec le statut
d'auto entrepreneur le texte juridique
qui entre en vigueur en ce mois d'août
en espagne le rassure donc une plus
grande protection allocations chômage
congés payés salaire minimum ou arrêt
maladie mais les livreurs se
retrouveront sans emploi à l'automne
l'entreprise a expliqué que l'espagne
représente une petite part de son marché
mondial et faire partie des leaders
représenterait un investissement trop
élevé et une rentabilité incertaine à
long terme des libéraux préfèrent donc
se recentrer sur d'autres pays les
syndicats des travailleurs en espagne
sont indignés je vous propose d'écouter
le responsable de l'association des
livreurs à barcelone
en tant qu'association nous avons alerté
le ministère du travail et les
organismes sociaux que sont les
syndicats cgt et force ouvrière de la
tragédie et l'impact social que peuvent
causer le départ d'une entreprise aussi
grande que des livres ou qui est cotée
en bourse comme le gouvernement n'a pu
trouver aucun accord avec l'entreprise
des libéraux a décidé de quitter le pays
or une telle décision a un impact sur
plus de 3000 employés en espagne nous
aimerions entreprendre des négociations
dans lesquelles se déciderait le futur
de l'entreprise et le futur des
travailleurs au sujet des indemnités de
licenciements et du chômage
de leur côté les entreprises
concurrentes comme globaux de justice
resteront présentes en espagne elles ont
eu trois mois pour s'adapter à cette
nouvelle loi près de 30000 livreur au
père pour ces géants du numérique en
espagne